let's go next to our caller from the 2:8
one area code who's calling today from
two eight one hello yes that's you who's
this okay this is Raj I'm from Texas
hey Raj to be specific yeah I've got two
questions I've been a member for two
years now so thank you you know keep
fighting good the first question is is
it worth bringing up the Democratic
primary
during our Thanksgiving holidays with
our relatives and stuff because I mean
like it and the thing is I really want
because you know I really only had a
chance to look at the most recent
climate report for anything the ICC that
they released last year and it's just so
alarming what's going to happen you know
even with the warming that we're already
projected to have that you know for me
it seems like any any time like there's
only two candidates in my mind that are
even legitimately addressing climate
change there's the urgency and maybe the
only word arguably only want to think
about Bernie's plan and so I don't know
like most of my family are well-off
suburb and I guess you know elite
liberals or whatever not really just
upper-middle income but I don't think
they don't have the same urgency that I
do when it comes to this election so
that was going to be my question my
first question was going to be are you
thinking about bringing up the
Democratic primary to Republicans or to
people on the Left who simply may not
have decided or may be going the wrong
way in the primary i if you're talking
here they're leaning yeah if you're
talking about a liberal leaning family I
probably would bring up that well what
state is this in by the way Texas but uh
suburbs of Austin actually okay so yeah
I didn't know if you were traveling for
for Thanksgiving or if it's happening
there here I would bring it up I mean
you know you want to bring it up in a
way that reflects the degree to which
you're willing to make people
uncomfortable or to start arguments and
it's totally reasonable not to want to
do that at Thanksgiving but I would
bring it up and I would gauge who are
people voting for and Texas is an
important state in terms of Delegates in
the Democratic primary so yes I would
bring it up but you know don't you don't
necessarily need to be accusatory or
attacking people but you
simply ask questions like if it you know
do you care they say I'm voting for
Biden or whatever okay well are you
concerned about the recreation with the
climate if they say yes then you say Oh
what is it that Biden plans to do and
then hopefully they will then realize oh
actually I don't know if Biden's
planning to do anything did you see what
Bernie's plan is on this and maybe you
can stimulate some Samrat in that way
well well that's the problem I think for
people that are generally doing okay in
life the moment that you say I'm with
Bernie I can I'm younger than all of
them right they're all older for
educated professionals have jobs all
that stuff I'm still in college
so the problem ends up becoming that oh
I'm with Bernie well you're an extremist
you know like you know like you
automatically get put into like you get
boxed in right and your arguments are
sort of brushed off just because you're
labeled great rather than you know
taking a objective look at the issues
and trying to understand what is the
most you know actual path that we need
to take we'll listen if you're called
annexed you can't go point/counterpoint
on everything but if you're called an
extremist for supporting Bernie I would
encourage you to say are Denmark Sweden
Switzerland Norway you know what I give
the full list are those countries
extreme because Bernie's not advocating
for anything more extreme than that
listen I wish you good luck and hope
hope you don't make any any enemies at
Thanksgiving yeah thank you so much I do
have a second question though part of
the problem I think was arguing for
Bernie is people don't perceive them to
be as electable quote-unquote which is
it honestly to me the just a completely
speculative concept electability but but
I do have a doubt in my mind about let's
say Bernie were to win the nomination
the only thing that I think I see
stopping him is all the special
interests will line up and just pour
mountains of money into the election
because he's such a fundamental threat
to the way things are do you see that as
a possibility that he may lose the
election just butyl interest you know
pouring all their money into the
election cycle it's certainly possible
but I think it's just as likely or
almost just as likely to happen with
Elizabeth Warren and I see them as
really the front-runner progressive
contenders so you know unless you're
saying let's just
go with Biden because the
special-interest will be less against
him if we want a progressive that will
that money will come out against Bernie
that money will also come out against
Elizabeth Warren so I think we're just
gonna have to fight that and beat it is
the only way around it listen I
appreciate the call I've got to run
because I've got a bunch of people that
want to get in here before we go on
Thanksgiving break